The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
RIK EBERHARDT: I
also had a couple
of students asking
me about, what
do you do after this class?
If you want to take more
classes in games, if you
want to take more
classes in game design,
if you're thinking about
the spring semester,
I just wanted to throw some
course numbers up here.
So there's CMS.301.
It's Introduction to
Game Design Methods.
If you're interested
in design research,
if you're interested
in design methods,
and you happen to also
be interested in games,
but you're likely going to
be doing things in design
elsewhere-- so that might
be application design,
toy design, anything physical,
anything game-like, whatever.
The methods they're
going to teach in there
are going to be useful
for all those things.
But the class is focused on
using game design as a way
to talk about design
methods-- so CMS.301.
CMS.608 is a class Phillip
teaches, and I co-teach
with him, on game
design-- so if you
want to know more about
how games are designed.
Some topics we talk about
are things like game balance,
tuning.
The projects are all board
games and card games.
So the entire class is done
with analog game design.
So we can actually get more
detail into how rules work,
how rules mix together.
We play a bunch of board games.
We analyze them.
And then we make board games.
It's very similarly
structured to this class.
It's team-based.
You'll do four game design
projects in that class.
There is CMS.610.
That is Media Industries and
Systems, the Art, Science,
and Business of Games.
That's taught by Chris Weaver
from Bethesda Softworks.
He worked on the Elder
Scrolls series for a while.
His class is focused on
the business and publisher
side of the equation
of game development.
So if you're thinking
about doing this
as a professional
career, at some point
you're likely going to have
to deal with publishers.
Either you're going
to be working for one,
you're at a studio that
will be working for one,
or you will be pitching
to one yourself.
So the big focus of
that class is the pitch.
How do you pitch your
ideas to another group?
And it's also
focused on the demo.
So if anybody's heard
of the term E3 demo--
basically how to make
your game look good
even though it doesn't work.
Hopefully the game
works at the end.
But it's really focused on,
what do you need in your game
in order to communicate
that game to another person
in order to provide
funding for your game?
So that's CMS.610.
It's a really great course.
He has a lot of really
good war stories
from what the game
development process
was like from the '80s on up.
And then lastly, CMS.617--
Sara and I teach that course.
It's called Advanced
Game Studio.
It's basically an independent
study, but with teams,
to make games.
You spend the entire semester
making a single game.
Sara and I act kind
of as your publisher,
kind of as your mom and
dad, kind of as your mentor.
Basically we are there to
help you make your game,
and to help your game
from start to finish.
But you have something
that you can either
submit to a festival, you
could show to another person,
or put in a portfolio.
Before you start this class,
you should be in a team already.
So we'll be sending
emails out about this.
We try to do a few
events in January
for networking and for people to
meet each other to form teams.
But you could form
teams with people
you've met in this
class and other classes.
I have a feeling that people
who took this class last year
are going to be looking
for teams for this year.
So there'll be some
emails going out
around December and
January, and hopefully
one or two events going on at
the Lab in January about that.
Yeah.
And then if anybody
has any questions
about if you want to
minor in games at MIT,
if you want to do a
concentration in games at MIT,
you can do that through
Comparative Media Studies
and Writing.
You can talk to me
about that after class.
You can also go to
the CMSW website
and talk to Rebecca
Shepardson about that,
and what the requirements
are for that.
It's comparative media studies,
so it's multiple media.
But games is one of
those media that you can
focus on and concentrate in.
OK.
So that is the advertisement
part of this class.
So today we're going to
finish up team formation.
I'm going to introduce the
Project 4 deadlines, which
I briefly mentioned last week.
And then we're going to
start Project 4 today.
You've got a lot of time
today to do brainstorming
and to do prototyping
in your teams.
We're recommending,
because you're
going to have
eight-person teams,
breaking up into smaller groups
to do some initial prototyping.
You want to basically
think of this as
prototyping as a
means of brainstorming
to come up with lots of
different kinds of mechanics
and actually try those mechanics
out, and play with them
a little bit, before
you decide on one.
We're giving you a
lot of time to do this
this week because we want
you to have something
playable by next Monday.
So that's that.
For teams, it sounds to me
like we had five topics that
were interesting to folks.
Is anybody still interested
in the malaria topic?
OK.
Not malaria.
Why do you let me come
up here and talk to you?
What was it?
Ebola.
Ebola, yeah.
So nobody was
interested in that.
All right.
So I've got early warning
leading to early action
for heat waves, cholera
prevention and hygiene,
forecast-based funding, SNAP,
and adapting to climate change.
Even though we've
got five topics,
that does not mean we need
to have one team per topic.
We can have multiple teams
doing the same topic.
And that's OK.
So raise your hand if you
don't think you're on a team
right now.
OK, that's a good
portion of you.
So what we're going to do
is, just like last time,
we're going to break up into
groups based on the room.
If you're interested in the
topic, go to that group.
Talk with those folks.
If you are in that group
and you signed off,
you said that you are
definitely on this team
through the mailing list,
identify yourself to the group
as yes, I signed up for
this on the mailing list.
This is what the team is so far.
Here are the people on
this team right now.
And actually, to help that
through, what I'm going to do
is put these on the board.
And then I'll have
people who signed up
for that team come down first.
And then everyone
else come down.
So over here, let's
do heat waves.
Over here, let's do cholera,
SNAP, climate change,
and forecast-based funding.
So if you are already
on one of these teams,
and you've said this is
the team I want to be on,
go to that area right now.
Ah, whatever.
That's OK.
All right, so heat waves--
one, two, three, four, five.
Cholera-- one, two,
three, four, five.
Cholera?
Six.
Cholera, seven.
Are you-- standing up--
anybody here on SNAP?
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven.
OK, cool.
If you're on SNAP, come on down
with the rest of the group.
Adapting to climate change--
if you're on the team,
or if you think you're
on that team-- OK.
And then forecast-based
funding, if you think you're
on that team-- one, two so far?
AUDIENCE: Everyone who
thinks they're on a team,
put their hands up.
RIK EBERHARDT: OK.
All right, so if we're going
to-- one, two, three, four,
five, six, there's only six.
OK.
So move to whatever team
you're interested in right now.
Talk with some folks.
If you're on the team already,
talk about some of the things
that you talked about last
week, brainstorming-wise.
If you want to be on that
team, talk with the members
and ask if you can be
on that team, basically.
I'm going to check in
on you in ten minutes
to see what it looks like.
AUDIENCE: Right now
it seems small enough
that we could be one team.
Also Liz wants [INAUDIBLE].
[SIDE CONVERSATIONS]
RIK EBERHARDT: All right.
After this amount of
discussion, how many people
are still undecided about
what team they want to be on?
Kind of undecided?
Anybody else kind of undecided?
All right, so if you
are 100% decided,
put your name on your post-it.
Put it up on one
of these things.
Do it really, really quick.
Come up.
Put it up.
Sit back down, please.
All right, so the dangers of
having more than 10 people.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
So in fact, there
is already dangers
of having eight people or more.
But this class was actually
intended for you to actually
feel that pressure, right?
When you've got an
eight-person team,
you're going to have
communication problems
up the wazoo.
That table might tip.
Be careful.
RIK EBERHARDT: It'll be fine.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
Your laptop's on it.
Once you get to a
10-person team, what
we've seen from
previous years is
that 10 people and larger
teams don't actually
outperform six-person teams.
They actually get about
the same amount done.
RIK EBERHARDT: Or less.
PHILLIP TAN: Or sometimes less.
Because the communication
overhead actually
breaks down further.
You might get a lot
of content done.
And it turns out to be
very uneven in quality,
because you have multiple
people doing content.
Now you could succeed
in breaking your team up
into little subgroups and be
able to organize yourselves
that way.
But we've never seen
it done successfully
in this class with students
with your level of experience.
So what we will recommend is
that if you've got something
like 12 people--
or 13 people, now?
RIK EBERHARDT: 13.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
You will probably get more done
by splitting into two groups.
If you are deliberately
brainstorming in order
to take advantage of 13
people, then of course
you're going to come
up with a game that
can only be executed by a
very large number of people.
What we're just saying is that
those games have traditionally
not done very well in our class.
They may be functional.
They may actually
deliver on the thing
that you intended to make.
But we've seen six-person
teams do much more.
Partly because they
iterate a whole lot faster.
And they may have smaller ideas.
But the ideas end up being
a whole lot more polished.
So that's our advice to you.
If they really want to
do a 13-person team,
are we going to let them?
RIK EBERHARDT: Um, wow.
Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: Against
our better judgement.
RIK EBERHARDT: Against our
better judgement, we might.
But what we're going
to ask, I think, today,
is to break up into two smaller
teams for brainstorming.
We actually want
all the big teams
to even break up
into smaller teams
anyway to do some brainstorming
and to do some prototyping.
Once you have all that
figured out, in class today--
by the end of class today--
you can decide how big
you want the team to really be.
The one issue that
we have, though,
is we've got some people
who are not in class today
who will be coming into class.
We've got the three
that we talked about.
There might be one or two more.
If there are any other
people like that,
they will be automatically put
on the smallest of these teams.
So I'd rather a
six-person in cholera
turn to seven, rather than
an eight turn into nine.
Because these eight-person teams
are actually just good enough.
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
The eight-person teams
are just about the size
that we were hoping for.
Six-person teams, actually--
to be perfectly honest,
I think the six-person
teams have an advantage.
But that's just how
the numbers break down.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
When we have seen a 10-person
team actually work, what really
happened was it was 10 people.
Eight of them
worked on the game.
Two of them worked on
the networking component.
The networking
component did not work.
Yet the game was
still as feature
complete as it could
be without networking.
It could work without
the networking.
That's not what
we're looking for.
We want the game that
you are submitting--
the game that you're creating,
the design document that you're
submitting to us on Wednesday,
and the game that you're
playtesting on Monday--
to be the actual game.
All those features
that you're saying
are going to be in that game.
We want that to be the
actual game that you submit
at the end of the semester.
So don't think of it as, well,
if two people flake, then
it's back up.
It's not.
If two people flake--
if you're too big,
and you've got two people who
don't know what's going on,
and they cause some
issues, it's just
going to be a disaster
for the entire team.
So this year, all of the
Project 2 and Project 3 teams
were actually bigger than we've
done them in previous years.
Previous years, they were about
four people, maybe five tops.
And we had you do six and
seven, I think, right?
Did anybody feel like with seven
people they got a communication
method that worked really well?
Like already--
PHILLIP TAN: I see--
what was the method?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
It's not perfect.
[INAUDIBLE]
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
It's the sort of thing
that-- whatever method
you use will definitely
improve with practice.
So if you've got something
that sort of worked well,
that's something you try again.
But the fact that most
people didn't should already
give you some warning
of what a large team is
going to feel like.
It's going to be tough.
RIK EBERHARDT: For the structure
of the class, on Wednesday
we're going to be talking about
more of the requirements--
the aesthetic requirements--
for Project 4.
We'll have basically
another design discussion
next Wednesday.
On Monday we're having a
short design discussion
about educational games.
And then we'll have one
of our first discussions
trying to talk about some of
the person-to-person issues
we see in making games.
In this case, it's
team dynamics, and how
to identify team dynamics.
We'll have a couple
more talks like that
to kind of help you get used
to running in a bigger team.
But between now and
next Monday, we're
hoping in class to
give you plenty of time
to actually work on some of it.
One of the biggest issues
with working in a big team
is just figuring out,
what is that core thing
that you're actually making?
What's the thing
that you're trying
to communicate to each other?
We've talked about how
you can use the division
document for that, and how you
can use the actual prototype
you make for that.
But often, it is
just having everybody
in the same room at the
same time talking and just
working together.
So we're trying to give you
as much time as we can--
PHILLIP TAN: In class.
because it's hard enough to
get six people outside of class
to meet up, let alone
an eight-person team.
Right?
So we're going to give
you more time in class
to meet up with each other.
That does not mean
that you should
be spending all your
time in class planning
on getting your
face-to-face coding done.
That's actually a waste of time.
Because you could be
talking to each other.
You can use it for
things like code reviews.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah, code
reviews, stand-up meetings--
things like that.
All right.
So we're going to put
this on hold for a second.
I'm going to go over, very
quickly, the deadlines.
And then we're going to
take a break and come back.
So if this will move
forward-- all right.
So why did I react so strongly
about the Animal Crossing,
all these sorts of mini-games?
It's because of what we're
asking you to do-- whoa.
Don't do that.
So what we're
asking you to do is
create a small, fully
functional, polished browser
game.
One of those many
games would count
as a small, fully functional,
well-polished browser game.
And we're asking you to use
the design iteration techniques
you've used in the past.
What does that mean?
We're actually talking
with the same design scope
as the previous two projects.
It's just you've
spent more time on it
to actually get it working
exactly the way you'd
want it to work.
It may be slightly larger.
So if your previous two products
had maybe one core mechanic
and one supplementary,
there might
be two supplementary
mechanics to that core.
But that's about it.
If you've got a game
that has an overworld,
then the overworld should
be the bulk of your game.
If the mini-games that
you decide to make
are the same size as
that overworld in scope,
that's already way
too over-scoped,
if that makes sense.
It's an eight week project.
You've got about two weeks to
concept and prototype multiple
game experiences.
So what we're asking for today
and tomorrow, or on Wednesday,
is you're not just
prototyping one game.
You're prototyping lots and
lots of different little games.
You're looking at
all of those games.
You're actually
going to have time
to spend on multiple
different prototypes,
rather than just a single
prototype that you iterate on.
So what we're
asking is if you've
got an eight-person
team, break yourself
into two groups of four,
four groups of two--
create some really small,
board-gamey-looking things,
some very small interactions.
Maybe they're playable.
Maybe they're something
you just describe.
But really go big blue sky.
And try to think of all
the different things that
can happen.
Because these topics that you're
dealing with are very large.
Make sure that your design
is grounded-- very, very
well-grounded-- in
the sources that we've
been given by the client.
There's going to
be multiple times
that they'll be here
to see your games
and talk about your games.
They'll be on your email,
so that you can ask them
questions about that as well.
So design constraints--
use all the mechanics
that we've been
practicing in class
with your previous projects.
PHILLIP TAN: Not all of the
mechanics simultaneously.
Use any of those mechanics.
RIK EBERHARDT: Any
of those mechanics.
So it could have trade-offs.
It could have randomness.
It is not required to have both.
It's required to have whatever
it takes for the topic
that you're working on, whatever
makes sense for the topic
that you're working on.
Those top two tend to be in the
realm of what those topics kind
of lean themselves towards.
But if you find
something else and you
want to use that
something else, great.
Spend some time
really working on it.
Spend a couple weeks
working on it before you
make a full commitment.
So your target audience--
each of those topics
has their own target audiences,
which they talked about.
The top three are the
ones to really focus on,
depending on your topic.
So Red Cross staff and
volunteers-- people
who are knowledgeable and
motivated about the topic
already, who just need a little
bit of extra information--
community organizers,
and then youth-- people
who are motivated, but maybe not
knowledgeable about the topic.
Again, the other requirements--
we are holding you to these.
Maximum play length
of 10 minutes.
Single or multiplayer game.
Test your user interface well.
It must use and play
audio for the player,
unless audio is absolutely
not required for your design.
If you design really
does not need audio,
then don't use audio.
But a, if it's a web
browser experience,
there probably
should be some way
to use audio as a method of
getting feedback to the player.
So it could be as simple as a
ding when something happens.
And that's OK for this project.
What matters to us is that you
have a unified aesthetic, which
we'll talk about on Wednesday,
what exactly we mean by that.
And then also we're asking
you to give design thought
to spectating users.
In the final
presentation, you're
going to be presenting the
games on the projector.
People are going to be watching
the game as it's being played.
They should be able to
understand how the game is
worked, just by watching it.
Maybe they might need
to watch it one or two
times to figure that out.
But they should be
able to figure out,
what are the things that
are going on in the game?
And how are all those
interactions happening?
So your deliverables--
that was from up till now.
So on Wednesday, turn in to
Stellar a high-level design
doc or "back of box"
copy-- the same form
we've been using previously.
It's some kind of
vision statement
that says at this
point, these are
what we think the
features are going to be.
If at any point you make a
significant design change that
says, our feature list
is going to change,
our game is going to
look different, update
that document.
You have up until the end
of the semester to do that.
And whatever you turn in--
whatever that document is
on the last day of class should
be what game you're turning in.
So that document and
the game should have
the same features in there.
But we would like to see any
changes that happen between now
and then.
We'd like to see how those
changes happen and why.
So reflect them in that.
On Monday, turn in
a product backlog.
You're going to do a two-minute
presentation-- the core
of your game design idea.
And then we're going
to do a playtest.
On the 27th, we are going
to have at least one,
possibly two, of our
clients in on that day
to play those games.
Jano and Jared--
both of them came
in for the first day of class.
They were not in class
when Pablo was on.
We are asking for some
kind of Sprint tasklist
to be submitted
to Stellar weekly.
What exactly that is is
completely up to you.
We've given you a
format that we like.
We've given you a method
that we know works.
If you decide to
change that method,
let us know what you decided
to change it to and why.
But whatever you
have-- every week,
I should be able
to go to Stellar
and see what tasks you have
to do for the next week's
worth of work.
We are asking for
product backlogs.
That's actually a concrete.
Please give us a
product backlog.
The
Format you use for the product
backlog doesn't matter to us--
the feature list, if it's
a list of user stories.
What matters is that all
the features that you think
are going to be in
the game are listed.
All the features that are
done are listed as done.
And you've done some
kind of estimation
on what size those features are.
And then we're going to have
you do two-minute presentations
in class.
And all these dates
are in Stellar,
in the Stellar calendar.
So the next two-minute
presentations
are also on November 12
and then November 26.
Any questions so far
about any of this stuff?
All right.
So the project is due on
Wednesday, December 10.
On Stellar, turn in all
of your previous builds,
your written postmortems,
your design change
logs, your updated document.
And this time we're asking
you for focus test reports.
There are in-class playtests
on the 27th, the 5th,
and the 24th.
Two of those can be used
for focus test reports.
The other two must be external.
And then, yeah.
We're going to have
postmortem presentations.
So on postmortem presentations,
instead of five minutes,
you're going to have 20 minutes.
We're asking for a polished
presentation of the work that
went into developing the
project-- all of the iterations
that you made.
So we want to know about
your design iterations
in this presentation.
We also want to know
those five-- what
went right, what
went wrong, what
was interesting in the project.
So that's about 10 to 15
minutes given on process,
and team management, too.
For all of your
games, someone who
hasn't played the game
before will play the game
live on stage.
So that's basically
one way for us
to see somebody who hasn't
played the game before try it
out and see how it works.
AUDIENCE: Who's in charge
of acquiring the person who
hasn't played the game before?
RIK EBERHARDT: It's a little bit
of you and a little bit of us.
We'll do the best we can.
So we're asking
guests to come in.
We're hoping our clients
are going to be in.
Some of them might have
already seen your games before.
Some of them haven't.
If you have friends,
we actually suggest
you bring in friends
to come in and to watch
the presentations--
maybe not play your game,
but play somebody else's game.
But we open the final
presentation to the public.
We have a rehearsal
on Monday the 8th.
And we have the final
on Wednesday the 10th.
So on Monday the
8th, you don't need
to do the play the game
part of the rehearsal.
But you do need to do
a full dress rehearsal
of the entire presentation.
And the reason why
we're doing that
is we're going to give you
feedback on that, on what you
might have missed,
and what we'd like
you to see in the presentation.
And you've got a couple
days to apply that feedback
to your presentation and to
make it better, basically.
And I think that's it.
Yeah.
That's all from the other day.
So any questions about the
postmortem presentations?
Previous years-- I'll send out
the link to previous years,
so you can see what
these tend to be like.
But we've recorded
them in the past.
So you can see what
other people have done.
And that'll go to the
Announcements page on Stellar.
All right.
It's 1:50.
Take a 10-minute break.
Come back at 2:00.
And work in your teams.
PHILLIP TAN: So the
rest of class today
is pretty much for you to
figure out what is this project,
and get working on who you're
going to be working with
and things like that.
So what we're going to first
do is the typical brainstorming
process.
We're not going to guide
it so much this time.
But just a quick reminder--
you want somebody
who is in charge
of facilitating it,
which means reminding
everybody what the problem is,
and also calling out people
who may have trouble getting
their words in
front of the group,
like people who are trying
to get in a word edgewise--
so basically moderating
a discussion.
And someone, of course,
should be taking notes.
We have our giant pads
of paper in front.
You can use chalkboards.
For the cholera team, we
suggest splitting in half.
But that doesn't
necessarily mean
that your brainstorming team
is necessarily your game team.
What we are thinking is
that after brainstorming you
will better know whether
your ideas can be
split into two projects or not.
Given how many cards
disappeared on there, we really,
really, really recommend
that you split in two groups.
But there may be a more
organic to split that.
Because your ideas may
actually fall down on a more
clearly defined lines.
I noticed that you already did
some brainstorming up there.
But think, what would you do
with half the size of the team?
Then after that,
have the discussion
about who is on which team.
By the end of class
today, you should
know exactly who
is on your team,
how to get in touch with
each other, what your email
addresses are, what
your phone numbers are,
or instant messaging
handles or whatever.
And make sure that
you've figured that out.
Let's see.
One thing that I wanted to
tack on to Rik's presentation
earlier about the expectations
for the postmortem--
we brought up the
person who has not
played your game before
coming up and actually playing
your game.
And I know some of you
might be worried about that.
Do be aware that however well
or badly that person performs,
no matter how much
they like the game,
or completely misunderstand
what your game's about-- that
is going to be, at best, 1.5%
of your total semester grade.
That's not really significant.
It's not going to
really swing anything.
So don't worry about it.
But we are actually using those
sessions to gauge usability.
To what extent have you
actually designed a game
to make your game easy
for people who've never
seen your game to get into it?
These are the things that we
want you to be iterating on.
want you to be catching for.
And without having a
real-life, high stakes--
there is going to be a
person who hasn't played
your game in front
playing your game--
you may not take
it so seriously.
So we want you to be
taking usability really,
really seriously.
That's why Rik said,
the scope of the game
doesn't necessarily
need to be all that
different from the past.
But the amount of polish,
the amount of time
that you've thought
through your UI--
it's what you should be
spending all your time on.
Finally, we're going
to go a little bit more
into games for learning
in the next week.
But one thing that we want
you to be thinking about
while you're brainstorming
is, of course,
what is the player doing?
Now if you're trying to teach
something to someone, if you're
trying to get them
in a situation
where they're learning
about a certain concept,
it is ideal if the thing that
you are trying to teach them
is actually the thing
that they are doing.
Now there's a couple
of other ways-- actual,
can we bring up
Constantine's slide?
Sorry.
The dongle's there, too.
There are a couple
of other things
that you probably are
already considering
putting into your game.
Things like, what is the theme?
I noticed the brainstorming
for the cholera
already started talking
about things like story line.
So does the theme of the
game actually match not just
the topic that you're
trying to teach,
but also the mechanics that
you're designing for it?
You want to be thinking--
and a couple of you
have already been asking--
about things like, who's
going to be playing your game?
What's the demographic?
Also be thinking,
what situation are
they likely to be playing in?
Are they likely to be playing
it on their own at home?
Is what you want to design for?
And you can specify this.
You can say, this
is a game that's
meant to be played by
an individual person
with an individual
computer on their own time.
Or this is meant to
be played in a group
like the SNAP game
was played in a group,
in front of everybody else.
And that, by the way, falls
into the framing idea.
What is the context in
which someone's actually
going to be playing the game?
To what extent have
they played games
like what you're describing?
If you are making some sort
of hard core strategy game,
to what extent do people need to
be familiar with strategy games
in order to be able
to play the game?
Or do they just
need to be familiar
with things like Facebook
games, for instance?
Or do you really want to make
a game that doesn't assume
much play literacy at all?
You want to be looking,
of course, at the data,
and that means all
of the material
that we provided you, as well
as any information that you're
looking at in Google searches
or academic research,
or information that you're
getting from your domain
experts, from either the
Humanitarian Response
Lab or the Climate Centre.
Is that right?
Yeah.
So make sure that
we are representing
that as fairly as we can.
Because this is a game,
you do have liberties to
at which point you can sort
of abstract out those numbers.
Maybe they're not mathematically
very, very precise,
because you're trying to get
a sudden feel of the game.
And that, of course, goes
into the aesthetics part--
not just the graphical
aesthetics, but the way
how your game feels.
If you're trying to represent a
really, really tense situation
on the ground, and the way
how your data model makes
it resolve makes it feel like
your game is really clinical,
and it's very, very easy
to deal with the situation
as long as you know the
tried and true formula,
then you're not accurately
representing the situation.
Even though you may be
accurately using data.
So make sure that
you're balancing
that aesthetic feel
together with the content
and whatever real world facts
you're putting into your game.
Because these games are all
really about real world things,
you might want to make sure that
your fiction and narrative is
something that's
not too fantastical.
Or at least, if there is
a fantasy element of it,
it is the part that
has least to do
with the believability
of the things
that you're trying
to communicate.
You can say that there is
a village or a city that's
dealing with a cholera
epidemic or something,
and that's not a real city
anywhere on a map of the world.
But you can look at
that city and imagine
this could be a real city
somewhere in the world.
You could go as
far as saying, OK,
this is like the dark ages
or something like that.
Because the disease
has certainly
been around for a long time.
But you want to be able
to keep reminding people
that this is a real thing.
If you say that this is a
science fiction thing where
you're on a different
planet and it's
a completely different kind
of bug that behaves exactly
the same as cholera--
I'm starting
to feel that maybe the
fiction that you're
creating for your game is
undercutting what you're
trying to get this game to
do, which is to actually teach
something real.
RIK EBERHARDT: To jump in
on the fiction narrative--
so things to think about.
Your games are being played
by a specific culture--
people with a specific
cultural background.
Especially the cholera
game will likely
be played by-- I
believe it was Ghana.
Yeah, it's Ghana.
So students who are in Ghana--
what kind of culture do they
have?
You're going to have
to research that
and figure that out
for those games,
to figure out what kinds
of common backgrounds
might they have that
you can talk about.
For the heat waves
game, that actually
has more of a focus on Red
Cross volunteers and university
students.
You can specify, we
understand that the people
who are playing this game are
likely going to be from Europe.
And they're likely going to
have this kind of background.
When you're creating your high
level game design document,
come up with what you imagine
your target audience to be,
so you have some kind of
cultural background to use.
Again, you're
choosing fiction that
is going to be so
supportive and helpful,
and not fiction that
might be not known
or might undermine the idea.
One thing to keep in mind
with the fantastical-- studies
have found that
some games-- when
it comes to pandemics
and outbreaks,
using the zombie fiction
actually can work sometimes.
There is something to be said
about using a common fiction
that people know.
People can say, all
right, I understand
how zombie pandemics work.
Because I've seen all
these films about it.
Whereas if you just told
me it was a disease,
I might not have
seen enough films
that had anything about how
disease actually spread.
So really think about
what is your problem?
What fictions might be useful?
What narratives might be
useful for the problem
that you're fighting?
PHILLIP TAN: Use fiction to
keep the topics relatable.
And if that means drawing on
things in popular culture,
that's great.
That's a tool in your hand.
Don't use fiction
as a way to paper
over design problems,
which I've often seen.
You know, if we set
this game in space,
then we can sort of skip over
all reality, or something
like that.
When you're brainstorming,
make sure you know what
you're brainstorming about.
Are you brainstorming mechanics?
Is it about what people
are going to be doing?
Are you brainstorming what
the fiction is going to be?
I would say do a separate
brainstorming session
for each one of these things.
Maybe just spend 10 minutes.
You don't have to brainstorm
every single thing
that we're showing you here.
You could brainstorm what is
they aim and impact that you
want to achieve in this game?
How are you going to do that?
Are all of you even
on the same page
about what you want your
game-- the kind of change
you want to see in the world?
And that's going
to be your purpose.
That is going to be-- do you all
understand what this thing is?
A lot of it has been
defined for you.
But I'm not guaranteeing
that everybody on your team
necessarily shares
the same idea.
So the brainstorming process
might be able to get that out.
And at some point in time
within the next couple of weeks,
you should have a
pretty good idea.
You should have had a chance
to at least talk with your team
about every one
of these elements.
This is a research
framework that's
been put together by one up
our colleagues, Constantine
[INAUDIBLE].
I think we can put
a link to this.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
I'll post the slides, and this
particular slide, to Stellar.
PHILLIP TAN: And
we might get back
to elements of this
later in the week.
But right now, this is
just basically something
to help guide your
brainstorming.
RIK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
Aesthetics we're
recovering on Wednesday.
Fiction we're covering
in a couple of weeks.
PHILLIP TAN:
Finally, one reminder
about brainstorming-- if your
brainstorming session runs
more than 10 minutes,
you'll want to flip
your secretaries around.
So that somebody
else is taking notes.
Let the person who's
been frantically writing
things down actually
get their ideas in, too.
OK?
We're not going to
time that for you.
That's going to be
something for you.
And once they've got their
teams, email, video game
bosses?
RIK EBERHARDT: Put
your vision statement--
it should have all your team
and all your member names in it.
And that's due on Stellar
on the date that it says,
on Wednesday.
PHILLIP TAN: So put all your
names in the vision statement.
The rest of class is yours.